[Música]
en 1864 el zoólogo francés august dil
quedó desconcertado mientras investigaba
el
ajolote A diferencia de muchos otros
anfibios que se transforman en adultos
terrestres los ajolotes conservan sus
características juveniles y nunca salen
del agua en un intento por inducir la
metamorfosis dumeril pasó meses
quitándoles las branquias pero la
mayoría de los ajolotes las regeneraba
de hecho los ajolotes son maestros de la
regeneración pueden regenerar
perfectamente partes del cuerpo de
miembros amputados y columnas aplastadas
a partes de ojos y el
cerebro Pero cómo lo hacen y qué otros
secretos guardan esta salamandra
extraordinaria es nativa de los
humedales de la Ciudad de México los
antiguos aztecas lo consideraban la
Encarnación de un Dios llamado
shotl de ahí el nombre del ajolote que
significa monstruo del agua los ajolotes
alcanzan la madurez sexual con branquias
y una aleta dorsal parecida a un
renacuajo los científicos creen que su
eterna juventud llamada neotenia
evolucionó debido a su hábitat estable
para las salamandras que se desarrollan
en aguas que se secan es esencial una
transición eficiente a la tierra pero
los lagos en los que evolucionaron los
ajolotes eran invariables durante todo
el año y no albergaban muchos
depredadores acuáticos los científicos
creen que fue ventajoso para el ajolote
renunciar a las exigencias de la
metamorfosis sin embargo no han perdido
esta habilidad por completo de exponerse
a ciertas sustancias el ajolote Se
volverá adulto pero a menudo tendrá
esperanza de vida más corta y perderá
algo de sus habilidades de autocuración
esta regeneración pareciera ser un
superpoder antojadizo pero los ajolotes
hacen muy buen uso de ella de bebés
están en competencia directa Entonces se
comen entre sí Esto no es un gran
problema Gracias a la rapidez con la que
pueden regenerar partes del cuerpo
cuando un ajolote pierde una extremidad
los tejidos estimulan el crecimiento en
la zona las células de la piel se
dividen y cubren la herida luego las
células progenitoras que pueden
desarrollarse en varios tejidos
corporales forman una masa en el sitio
de la lesión y los nervios cercanos
secretan proteínas que promueven el
crecimiento En las siguientes semanas
surge una nueva extremidad conforme las
células
proliferan este proceso podría en
potencia llevar a un crecimiento
descontrolado y formación de tumores
pero los ajolotes son notablemente
resistentes al cáncer tienen un sistema
que controla firmemente la proliferación
celular para comprender mejor la
biología de ajolote los científicos
secuenciaron su genoma descubrieron que
era más de 10 veces más largo que el del
humano las mutaciones pueden cambiar la
longitud del genoma de cualquier animal
las salamandras tienen mucho más ADN que
otros vertebrados porque pierden partes
de ADN con menos frecuencia al
investigar el genoma del ajolote los
científicos vieron muchas secuencias
repetidas la mayoría de las cuales no
codifica proteínas y no tiene funciones
conocidas también encontraron genes
claves para la generación pero el factor
más importante de la regeneración de la
jolote puede que no sea un conjunto de
genes únicos sino cómo regulan sus genes
no es de extrañar que los ajolotes sean
uno de los animales más estudiados pero
su población natural ha caído en picada
hace cientos de años los ajolotes
proliferaban en la capital Azteca en los
lagos circundantes los aztecas
construyeron Islas llamadas Chinampas
para cultivos esta forma de agricultura
altamente productiva creó un vasto
sistema de canales que expandió el
hábitat de sistema lacustre poco
profundo y protegido el entorno ideal de
los ajolotes pero cuando llegaron los
españoles comenzaron a drenar los lagos
y en los últimos años se ha desviado más
agua actualmente toda la población de
ajolotes silvestres se encuentra en un
solo lugar el lago de sochimilco donde
están amenazados por la contaminación y
los peces Invasores la gente trabaja
para regenerar el ecosistema y
fortalecer los 2000 años de tradición
agrícola de la chinampa si crece el
interés los agricultores podrían
recuperar Chinampas abandonadas y apoyar
a la comunidad local y a la jolote
eventualmente los beneficios de salvar a
esta salamandra podrían Ser aún mayores
los científicos esperan algún día
aplicar la magistral supresión tumoral
de la jolote y sus habilidades
regenerativas al cuerpo humano quizás
sus secretos sean la verdadera razón de
la sonrisa del monstruoso Dios
viscoso hablando de criaturas extrañas
Cómo llegaron a vivir los gatos en
nuestras casas conozca la historia de la
domesticación de gatos con este video y
suscríbase a nuestro canal para
satisfacer su
curiosidad